my family's always been i've been super
lucky with having a supportive family
from throwing every cast party for every
school show that we ever did to driving
me to rehearsals and sitting in the car
outside for three hours until we were
done like I could not have asked for a
more supportive amazing family they're
kind of I really don't know if I would
still be chasing it without their
support and help you know and I mean
that's a that's a huge thing for actors
is whether it's your family or your
friends like you need to find that
support system you need someone to lean
on in those bad times and to celebrate
with in those good times you know so I
would say that's that's a little piece
of advice do you find that support
system to help you keep your sanity you
know it's interesting because I've heard
of very I never hear a gray example I
always hear either i have a really
supportive family or you hear these sort
of true Hollywood story non-support and
the people that made it through despite
that or whatever yeah I find that
interesting it seems like there's
they're usually people aren't that
there's not on the fence I mean either
we're in with him or we're not my
parents have always been in with me but
one of the first things they said was
like you're the first one in the family
who's ever gone down this path you know
so they were like we we don't know what
to do to help you will do whatever needs
to be done but you need to tell us
because we have no clue what to do so
they were like the perfect supportive
parents because they weren't stage
parents they didn't push me to do things
if they saw an audition they tell me
about it but if I didn't want to go on
it they would be like okay go play in
the yard do whatever you want to do be a
kid so it was like it was perfect i
really couldn't ask for anything better
and i know i'm lucky for that because
like you're saying not everybody has
that support system but i think i think
you can seek it out and find it if you
don't have it
actually at home you know like theirs
theirs especially with social media and
all that stuff now there's communities
that all help each other out and lift
each other up you know and also too I
think sometimes people they don't mean
to be ill intentioned or whatever but
they're just scared for their son or
daughter yeah brother sister I know I've
heard that too like oh I want them to do
this but I'm I'm afraid for them no well
it's it's a hard life unless you I mean
there what's the statistic there's
40,000 two actors and sag at any given
time and less than one percenter working
you know the numbers are not on your
side going into this career and most of
those times the people who are not a
hundred percent behind you it's probably
because they think they're being
supportive in their own way they want
you to have a comfortable life you know
and I mean that is something to think of
when you're deciding to actually go down
this road you know I've had months word
you how are we paying rent you know and
then of course you book something and it
comes along and you find a way but yeah
it's a I've definitely had I've had
great years and I've had horrible here
is you know so it comes with the
territory and you got to just be able to
ride through those valleys you know
because that's like keeping your sanity
during the low points it's a big part of
the game yeah anything to I think it's
just someone saying I believe in your
choice to live authentically and not I
know you can't really make money at this
I want you to be a corporate drone yeah
and kill your soul and unless that's
what you want you right selling widgets
or whatever but I think the fact that
someone saying no matter what happens I
believe in you to live authentically I
think that's a huge yeah you know that
really probably boosts people up for
sure I mean yeah it the support from my
family definitely has helped me
immeasurably
you